a fire on board forced a JetBlue flight
to make an unexpected landing in
Michigan a passenger first reported
smelling smoke that was coming from a
carry-on bag DeMarco Morgan is here with
how the fire was caused by a lot a
lithium battery in a laptop officials
believe DeMarco good morning good
morning Gail flight 915 left New York's
JFK Airport early Tuesday evening and
was headed for San Francisco
not long after smoke started pouring out
of a backpack that's when the pilot
decided to divert to Grand Rapids
Michigan we just got the pilot and he
reported that it was a battery fire from
a laptop in the passenger compartment
surely after JetBlue flight 915 left to
New York Tuesday passengers on board
started to notice something was wrong
we're at 35,000 feet and all of a sudden
we hear our announcement and we look
back in row 25 and we saw everybody
standing up and smoke coming around we
didn't know what was going on passenger
alan hana ball was on the flight with
his daughter Kaylee
I had no idea what's going on I was kind
of scared I didn't know what to think
she says the smoke came from a portable
laptop charger in a backpack the fire
was out before they landed but the plane
was on the tarmac in Michigan for nearly
three hours as emergency crews removed
the device and meat inspections any
injuries on board from the fire that's
where we're at a statement JetBlue
confirmed flight 915 diverted following
reports of smoke emitting from a
carry-on bag holding an electronic
device lithium batteries have drawn
attention recently for unexpectedly
catching fire in some devices most
rechargeable electronic devices like
laptops are powered by lithium ion
batteries according to the FAA this year
there have been 12 fire related
incidents on flights caused by lithium
batteries or lithium battery power
devices and as the Department of
Homeland Security considers a ban on
laptops on flights from Europe US
carriers are expressing concerns over
storing lithium powered devices and
cargo holes where a fire could burn
unchecked
now passengers say crewmembers responded
quickly to the incident and everyone
remained calm like nine fifteen landed
safely in San Francisco early this
morning Charlie
DeMarco thank you